mutter in die hölle hallo meine lieben
freunde herzlich willkommen rostig und
wir geben natürlich wieder voll lassen
wir das von uns gewohnt seid wir werden
jetzt endlich mal einfach so old school
kommentar den ich brauch erst mal mit
stein hier einfach komplett aus gameplay
nicht hier bei ihnen welche fragen über
irgendwelche themen einfach hier jetzt
rüber dahin ich glaube ich hätte ein
bisschen hoch machen mag ich liebe das
ipad 2 die orks und die perfekt alter
die anderen sechs rollt bald wieder
erste der in der mitte ist dann werde
ich probiere alles gut wird zwei bis
leicht überfordert mit der situation
aber was wir haben zwei bögen was
passiert in okay ich war eben das bett
hier ein bisschen anwender darüber kommt
in aller welt
das runter gefallen
die grünen euro will mich gerade so wie
wenn ich in der mitte laufe dann nach
links
er ist seit 1901 kennen ich tatsächlich
okay ich gehe mutig aber enorm bringt
also mein gott oh mein gott oh mein gott
oh mein gott oh mein gott mein gott
manchmal ist das schwarze schaf gott
mein gott ich glaube ich war unterwegs
sind wir geld sind wir wesentlich gelb
oder nehmen sie ruhig wie blöd ok schade
ich laufen damit ich jetzt ein bisschen
rüstung oh mein gott hat nichts passiert
so dass bei dir irgendwie der pc na gut
wenn der pc ausgegangen das gehört aber
wer hat noch im ersten bogen weiter das
ist jetzt noch keiner glaube ich also
noch niemand von uns gesehen hätte
alles weitere insel massiv dieses tempo
aus elz diese fusion ihre seine augen
augarten bogen kampf hier
das ist echt hier wieder an spannung pur
man wie scheiß war dass der wieder von
mir sein müssen
ich wollte zu bekommen die zu zweit auf
mich zugestürmt schwertern ich dachte
ich packe da ist und nicht zu schnell
sein es kann nicht sein dass gar kein
garnichts abgebaut worden ist gerade auf
dem web ist so so essenziell
also so krass sieht man eigentlich
normalerweise direkt ja der ist echt
noch gar nichts abgebaut ist das ist für
die aus- und extrem komisch einfach
normalerweise doch bei diesem match
immer so ja direkt erst weg nach einer
sekunde
also ich meine ich hatte auch schon
zweimal die chance einfach nicht
hinbekommen dieses mal ist ja auch kaká
so schallt es stimmt dass mit kriegen so
erstmal einfach gelb ihr weg gefallen
hat und recken nerven natürlich extrem
diese wolken hier so ich bin bei villa
ab bei grün bei uns läuft jetzt in
dieser zu zwei gründen ok als neues von
dem ok fresh meinst du schaffst du flott
zu töten einer läuft in die mitte
blockiert er der einst in der mitte
ich habe ihn habe ich komplimente
ja ich habe einfach grün noch getötet
winkels täglich sieht man diesen nicht
kopf ich bin bei grün aber er hat
wahrscheinlich volle lehrte volle leben
verdammt naja egal wer das ist auf jeden
fall wir sind ein wenig mit dabei habe
ich eigentlich wieder für eine chance
respekt ja wieder wenn ich mich so
richtig konzentrieren da drauf so hier
in kettenhemd holen ich noch ein
bisschen reisen zu wollen eigentlich
geht man raus haben aber das ist keine
entspannung pur hier irgendwas sagen
also entweder speed runs oder oder so
gute und wo man auch echte gegner haben
alle hatten hotspot machen einen
streifen spaß tatsächlich wo ich habe
zehn gold ok garlstedt nicht sicher ist
man das gold ein bisschen rot grün kommt
von einer seite glaube ich nicht bald
zum eisen zu weisen ok alles gut
okay okay ich hab nix im namen von mir
egal sein ob ich bin nicht dafür hat er
das xds hat er sich geleistet
ich habe jetzt ein paar corner kommt der
kommt erst in der mitte der
unterliegende ja ich bin erzählt wie das
monster bisschen also wenn einer unserer
bett abbauen sollte dann ist das echt
eine meisterleistung weil wir haben
einfach so viel von diesen steinchen
hier rumstehen und den kassen von den
krassen stein
das wird schon krass wenn das einer
krass gras krass aus einer kraft die
mutter in die hölle du bastard und das
ist natürlich schön wenn man solche
mitspieler hat
er liebt einfach jemand oder haben einen
gleichnamigen youtube kanal dann dann
werden sie die dann ist wieder so ganz
kleinlaut auf einmal zur ja sonst mache
ich das nicht aber in der aufnahme jetzt
tut mir leid klagte der mitte grüne
kenntlich genauso grün oben war du hast
das ich habe genau gleich mal
angeschossen habe ich auch später
vielleicht also eigentlich könnten wir
die nesseln glaube ich ich weiß nicht
auf ihren bogen können würde ich mir
okay wenn ich jetzt unterhalb kicken
oder probiere mich runter zu kippen
okay es ist okay wenn beide dauern müsse
müsse jetzt laufen occupy die note gut
freunde das war eine runde hat jetzt
neun minuten wieder es war auf jeden
fall an spannung pur
ich würde auf jeden fall sagen es euch
gefallen habe ich mich über eine
bewertung freunde haben auf stur mattes
kanal auch nach unten gezeigt könnt ihr
auch stumpfes kanal nachschauen es steht
oben in der beschreibung und dann sehen
wir uns bei einem anderen video wieder
irgendwann groß großkunden war das groß
so groß ich habe jetzt einen kuss kuss
kuss oder schließen